la maire de paris anne hidalgo le député
insoumis françois ruffin ou encore
l'écologiste josé bové tous appellent au
boycott d'amazon pour noël dans une
pétition lancée sur internet vous êtes
client d'amazon amazon le leader a
contesté du e-commerce en france
son fondateur c'est l'entrepreneur
américain jeff bezos en 2000
l'entreprise ouvre son premier entrepôt
en france à boigny championne dans le
loiret plus de dix mille mètres carrés
des milliers de références de livres ou
de céder et à la clé une trentaine
d'emplois créés une aubaine pour
l'économie locale selon le maire de la
commune image de marque d'amazon est
quelque chose qui valorise le parc
technologique après boigny sur bayonne
d'autres sites sont construits comme à
sarran en 2007 ou montélimar en 2010
amazon créateurs d'emplois oui mais
voilà en échange le géant américain
reçoit d'importantes subventions de la
part des pouvoirs publics comme ici avec
le centre de distribution de chalon sur
saône en 2012 pour chaque emploi créé
ici le département a dépensé mais 100
euros la région 3400 l'état jusqu'à 2000
soit pour chaque employé jusqu'à 6500
euros la première année chez certains
habitants de chalon sur saône
ces aides publiques ne passe pas dans
d'autres entreprises si je mériterai je
pense d'un coup de main avant de
privilégier ces grands groupes
en plus de ces subventions amazon
pratiquer l'évasion fiscale
la société ne fait pratiquement aucun
impôt en france car son siège social est
à l'étranger
c'est donc au luxembourg que
l'entreprise américaine p la majeure
partie de ses impôts
une aberration pour cet élu de saône et
loire quelle image vis-à-vis des
citoyens l'on donne en donnant de
l'argent public une entreprise qui doit
juste franc de l'argent au fisc
je trouve quand même 7 cet acte
complètement immoral
malgré ces critiques ça n'empêche pas
emmanuel macron tout juste élu président
de la république d'inaugurer un nouvel
entrepôt en 2017
mais en 2019 nouvelle polémique
selon une étude du député lrm mounir
mahjoubi amazon est accusé de détruire
des emplois en france pour un emploi
créé par amazon +2 2 sont supprimés dans
le commerce traditionnel et amazon a une
particularité ce qu'ils sont extrêmement
productif c'est à dire que pour le même
chiffre d'affaires ils ont besoin de
beaucoup moins de personnes donc à
chaque fois qu'ils prennent une part de
marché
ils détruisent des emplois aujourd'hui
amazon se retrouve encore sous le feu
des critiques
pourtant à la proche du black friday une
majorité de français entend faire ses
achats sur internet selon une étude
76% d'entre eux comptent acheter sur des
sites comme amazon ou cdiscount
en revanche ils ne sont que 25% à
plébisciter les petits commerçants
[Musique]